Hi, I'm Paul Bakaus and
I'm a Developer Advocate at Google.
In my previous role as Studio CTO
at Zinga, it's my full time job
to have my team tooled up to be as
productive and happy as possible.
>> And I'm James Williams.
A Course Developer here at Udacity,
where I make Android and web courses.
In the next few lessons, we're
going to teach how do you use tools.
Okay, not these tools, but these tools,
to help you become a better and
more efficient web developer whether
you're just starting out, or
have been around for
a while and want to freshen up.
>> So, how are we going to do this?
>> You're going to stay here and
translate all the tooling mumbo jumbo
into English, and
explain the ideas and concepts.
>> Well, then you have to make sure
that all the material stays in long term
memory by quizzing our students and
so on.
Now, here's a quick disclaimer.
I promise you come out here supercharged
and more productive than ever.
It's going to involve a lot of
fiddling with the terminal,
a lot of keyboard shortcuts and
general groundwork.
Or guard work, I should say,
but we'll get to that later.
But we'll try to spice it
up as much as possible.
>> All right, let's talk about
what you'll learn in this course.
We'll kick it off with setting
up your developing environment,
to achieve that perfect flow.
>> Finally, let's get you a coworker
that you can delegate tasks to,
your build process.
And then we'll dive into all
the things our fellow is good at.
Expressive life coding,
preventing yourself from disasters, and
saving a lot of time and
effort with automatic optimizations.
>> So let's get going.